yeah and thank you very much for giving
me an opportunity to
present something about schrodinger
which is a really exciting
software suit which has many things
to do in in the field of computer editor
design
and i hope at the end of this
presentation
everybody will get to know about uh more
about schrodinger suit
and what are the things which are
present with the schrodinger software
and what are the things which you can do
actually
so this is what uh i would like to say
so before starting the presentation uh
i would like to tell you one thing that
i am going to cover mostly on
the software aspect of rolling a suit
including little bit basics of computer
editor designing
and in general truck designing and
finally i will also touch up upon the
case study like how efficiently one can
use software
to get the best result out of it and uh
truly uh said by uh mr raghu in the
short introduction like there were a few
case studies by schrodinger
itself even as a software company we
have
our own drug discovery group and that
works on
some critical problems in drug discovery
and we got success actually
and i will briefly touch upon it but
but in detail like we will see it in the
upcoming presentations what it is about
but i will just
touch it touch it upon various topics
so i hope at the end you will like it so
before starting the presentation
um so can anybody please confirm
sonalika whether
the screen is visible and my voice is
yes so your screen is visible
okay great so yep so
i would like to start from instead of
just
starting the presentation here is my
email id
so even you can note it down and in case
of any queries or if
questions are not addressed here in this
particular presentation or if you want
to consult us
further do not hesitate to write me back
so i'll be always happy to help you out
and provide the suggestions so please
be in touch and please feel free to
write me
so with this uh like i will be mostly uh
focusing on how one can transform the
drug discovery
using computational modeling and i would
say more
advanced methods of computational
modeling so most of the time you have
heard of molecular docking but there is
uh
there is a lot more in the field of
computer aided drug designing and this
is what we are going to see
now so if you talk a little bit
about uh if you know about drug
designing so
or how how do like drug gets developed
or how it binds to the receptor so
basically if you go
really uh into the basics uh
you for every drug like it must have
some
target where it gets bind and show some
pharmacological action
so this all resembles to the like local
key model
in very simplistic way you have a lock
you have a key
and then your key fits into lock it
when you move your key it induces
something some changes inside the lock
we call it as a conformational changes
and somehow it change the internal
structure of
lock and your lock gets open or it gets
close
so for that what is important thing is
first of all like those conformational
changes which are happening inside the
lock
and the key which by using that thing
we can make those conformational changes
and we
need to know that thing like key is very
much specific to lock
so not every key fits in every lock so
your key and lock combination is very
much unique
and now let's come to the biology and if
you see like
there are many such keys are available
in the world
but for your lock with just a single key
which works very fine
so see same way there are many chemicals
which are available
in the chemical space and its number is
10 to the power 16
that many huge number of possible
chemicals are available
but for the particular receptor or for
particular so in our case in our body
the receptor is nothing but the protein
it can be dna from the rna
so it's a biological molecule so for
that
particular protein you have a particular
key and
whole idea of drug designing is to find
that particular key which fits
best in your lock means that particular
protein
so so there are various ways to find out
that key
which fits particularly inside the lock
but
uh as uh told by mr raghu that before it
was a serendipity like
people used to try many keys and out of
that maybe they could find one key which
fits better
and such accidental discoveries do
happen just like a blockbuster truck
paracetamol you have like it was
discovered long time back and
it is still working very fine but there
was no
uh such a hardcore research or computer
editor design things were involved in it
but nowadays like uh
because of emergence of this method so
what is uh what do you get
because of those emergence of these
computers and computer editor designing
methods is you will get the microscope
what microscope you will get the
molecular microscope through which
basically you can see the struct
internal structure of lock
like how the lock looks like so same way
if you know the internal structure of
locks you know where are the keys where
are the
levers so you can design your key in a
better way
so the same thing is applied to the
receptor you have a protein structure
and if you could see
inside that protein structure what are
the amino acid residues present inside
it what are the functional group present
inside it how it looks like what is
shape of it
then definitely you can design a better
lock a better key
or better molecule again so this is what
the advantage you get it uh because of
computer-related drug designing methods
so we call it as a molecular microscope
because you will be able to see
everything at atomic level detail
and consider schrodinger suit as a
molecular microscope so it allows you to
see what is inside
the lock what is inside the proteins
and with the help of that we proceed
further with the designing of molecules
so even computer-aided drug designing
it's a vast field there are many things
which are involved in it
but overall uh when we talk about drug
designing it is broadly classified into
structure based drug designing and
ligand-based drug designing
so here whenever we say structure to
structure resembles to the structure of
receptor
and structure of log structure of
protein so if you have that information
available with you means the structure
of protein then we can go for structure
based methods like
molecular docking molecular dynamics
simulations but
there can be a case when you don't have
information of structure of
your receptor in that case we can also
rely on ligand-based methods like format
for qsar methods or shape-based
screenings
so we are going to see all those methods
there are many such methods which are
available
inside this structure base and
ligand-based methods and we are going to
see it in subsequent sessions
but right now we will mostly try to
understand what it happens actually
so yeah overall like we mostly deal with
the molecular docking process in which
we
have a receptor structure so protein
looks like something like this
it's a huge structure it has particular
shape it has particular volume
it has particular binding pocket and
with the help of
software we try to dock the millions of
compound inside the protein structure
millions of compound with millions of
keys and
out of those millions of key with the
help of molecular docking we generate
various poses calculate their energies
we try to identify a suitable key which
fits better inside the binding pocket
and then we try to further modify that
key using
uh further substitutions on it so in
this way we try to
optimize that lead molecule and we
calculate various parameters like
energy its interaction and based on all
those things
we try to shortlist the best molecule
out of it
and this is the molecule we often take
it further and we go for synthesis and
we check
its biological activity so this is what
the minimum thing which we do in
computer aided drug designing and again
let me tell you this is the minimum
thing which we do
but the sky is again open for you there
are many methods which are available
so before proceeding and for knowing
more methods like it is worth to know
the history of it like from where it
started
so maybe many of you are aware of this
history or many of you are
unaware of this history but it is
history is always interesting
so it is better to know it so from where
it all got
started so it was started really long
time back
if i remember correctly it's a 1960s
when uh there was a scientist called
martin karplus
like he's still alive the scientist is
still alive and
so in 2013 uh if i'm not wrong he got
the nobel prize for his discoveries
and his discovery was developing a force
field
so it all started in that time 1960s
like during his phd he developed force
field and later on he continued with it
so force field was really necessary for
studying those molecules or studying the
structures
as a molecular model so
imagine like in 1960 we started and then
people started working on in mostly in
academics and then it took around
30 years to develop that field and
successfully applied into the field of
drug designing
so the successful example was first
reported by about laboratories and it
was on hiv protease
so they developed hiv proteas inhibitor
using this rational
designing which is help of computers so
this is the first reported study was in
early 1990s so you can imagine like it
took 30 years to develop that field and
actually implementing
it and after that discovery when that
paper got published
everybody came to know like it was a
revolution in the field of drug
discovery like because people
got something to see inside the protein
structure and that is what your
molecular modeling software is
so the thing is after that like
every pharma company every economics
started using all those software started
even developing updating that software
and then rest is the history so there
are many such very well known drug like
you haven't you have often heard of any
flu
if you start searching for computer
editor design success story
this was one of the uh starting first
example like
who got success time if you and there
are many such drugs which are
successfully developed through computer
educator designing and
nowadays like every single drug which
you think of
like it passes through the process of
computer editor designing
because it is method of virtual
screening the fastest method
so there are many such examples by
various companies
and you can find all those things in a
literature also
so uh what is basically the power of all
this
technique technique of molecular
modeling so here is the video which
deficits the power of it like
up to what extent one can study the
biological phenomena or physical system
with the help of computers
you really don't need to look at water
in the glass
but you can simply perform molecular
dynamic simulations of water
and different temperatures so let me
tell you the example so this is what the
first left hand side video you can see
it is basically a
molecular dynamic simulation of water so
you have a single water which is present
here
at the meter middle red is oxygen white
is
hydrogen and which is surrounded by
other water molecules and we simulated
it
at a basically room temperature where
water stays at
liquid state and you can see this yellow
dash lines are nothing but the
intermolecular hydrogen bonding which
are happening with the surrounding water
molecules
and if you can carefully see you can see
at any given point this particular
single water molecule is forming
around four hydrogen bonding
interactions with surrounding water
so this is what is the reason why water
stays in a
liquid state at room temperature but now
let's take
another example i increase the
temperature again in the computers
virtually i am doing all those things
when we increase the temperature up to
the boil boiling point and you can see
when we simulate the
you can suddenly see the water molecule
and the number of hydrogen bondings are
reduced to two or three so at any given
point it is forming two
hydrogen bonding interactions means less
number of hydrogen bonding interaction
and
that prompters uh the software uh sorry
the
water goes into gaseous phase so this is
what well-known phenomena it has
it reduces the intermolecular hydrogen
bonding interaction because of increase
in temperature
and when it happens the state of water
get changes from
liquid to gaseous phase and you can
capture this
complete phenomena with the help of
computer and the simulation so you
really don't need to look it at
a water place in your
beaker or you don't need to boil it you
can just do it in a computer so this is
what the importance of computer
editor designing and field of molecular
modeling so you can all simulate
everything in the
computer itself so uh other than that
like it is what to know like from where
it started so when
all those things started developing and
you can see like industry started using
it so
it was in the late 90s then when two
scientists came together
professor richard fishner and professor
william godard
from columbia university and california
institute of technology they came
together they were
really imminent scientists in the field
they are still alive
so they are a founder of schrodinger's
software so
they started uh basically developing
this software they thought okay this is
the software
which is the future and then they
started working on the field they
started developing the software each
module one by one
so looking um with the mission with the
single mission of course to improve the
human health and quality of life
by revolutionarizing this particular
drug discovery
and not only drug discovery but one can
use
or you can study various materials also
with the help of computational methods
so this is what their aim was and they
started
uh implementing all those things in the
software and they
started growing it one by one one by one
and now after
like 30 years this is the complete
software suit which we have
which has number of modules present and
across the globe like
as a schrodinger company has grown that
much that across the globe
presents at various places mostly our r
d team lies in eastern and western coast
of usa but other than that in uk germany
india and japan also we have
office where we do interact with the
scientists
who are using their software
and then what comes with the schrodinger
suit is there are various type of
small substitutes which are a part of
complete schrodinger suit
so it can start with the simple way of
visualizing molecule in the pi
mole or if you are working in case of
dnas proteins rnas antibodies antigens
so we have a
tool called biologic suit where all
modules come together to help you to
study
all biological molecules and if you are
interested in drug discovery means small
molecule drug discovery so we have a
special
soup for that which which has all
compiled compilation of all modules
which are necessary for
drug designing and not only that even
for materials if you want to study
materials like batteries
nanoparticles carbon nanotubes so all
those things
one can study using material science
suit you will be surprised to know that
even isro can use materials and so they
are also using it
uh not only is slow but boeing also so
in this way like
it has a wide usage and
not only that even discovery informatics
is the small
substitute package which we have which
helps you to analyze the huge amount of
data
which is generated by day to day
exercise in the field of chemo
informatics
so this is all come together with the
schrodinger suit complete package
so let me introduce those uh package in
a particular way like
in case of small molecule drug discovery
suit which helps you to
assist with the particularly drug
discovery process order discovery
methods so we have various tools like
for example which i have shown
uh which is most widely used is protein
ligand docking in which one can perform
molecular talking of huge library of
compounds
in fastest way inside the protein
structure
not only that but in in case of general
molecular docking or traditional
molecular docking we consider protein as
a rigid molecule
but uh with the help of another module
called induced fit docking which is
again part of floringer suit
we can also consider the binding pocket
amino acid residues of protein as a
flexible so that it helps you to
understand
the protein structure and its
conformational changes in better way
not only that there are various
ligand-based methods as i said like
pharmaco4 based methods or shape
screening in which
one can use this method to screen the
like uh compounds so for example you
have
active molecule for example paracetamol
so if you want to
uh look something which looks similar to
paracetamol you can use the form of 4 or
shape screening
to look for similar type of molecule
from the whole database of billions of
compound
and similarly there is a method called
3dqsar through which one can generate
various contours and understand the
chemistry of that particular
molecule and accordingly you design the
number of compounds
so there can be a case when we uh
we don't have like information about the
binding site which is
in the protein structure so we have a
tool to analyze that particular binding
pocket uh using
site map so sitemap is the name of tool
which helps you to
see what is basically present inside the
protein structure or inside the binding
process so this is what i was talking
about
so if you know what is inside the lock
so this is what the tool which helps you
to see what are the various properties
inside the lock and inside the protein
structure and once you get that
information one can of course use it for
the drug designing
then next thing comes into like core
hopping so for hopping or scaffold
hopping if you have heard of
so this is the method which is very well
known uh
using the field of drug discovery by
industries
to generate a new structure of molecules
uh
to skip the existing patterns even so
you can uh basically look for various
type of cores which are not exist
not existing in any reported pattern and
in this way they can get to know about
novel molecules and they can patent it
and of course like they can a lot of
money out of it
uh so you can also perform various type
of energy analysis
on the proteins or protein ligand
complexes to understand it better like
which
functional group of protein is more
important for
binding to the receptor energetically
how favorable it is and that can be done
other than that uh basically there is
one revolutionary tool called
library enumeration so you can see like
you have a ligand which has some
basic structure which is constant and
one can generate basically billions of
compound just by single click
and performing various substitution at
the given point so
this is called as combinatorial
chemistry like
you don't need to draw each structure
one by one and generate a lack of
compound no that is not the smart way of
doing it so smart way of doing it is
enumeration
automatic enumeration you just need to
tell the software okay i want uh
substitution at this particular position
and software will do all type of
possible substitution in it
so this is what is present with the
schrodinger suit and i must say it is
very much revolutionary in nature
other than that if you go for advanced
level of molecular modeling
and so you often heard of the term
molecular dynamics simulations in which
so here we talk about actually
simulating the biological system in
biological environment how it looks like
if you increase the temperature how it
is actually present inside the cell
inside the body
so we call it as a molecular dynamic
simulation and we can simulate it in a
real time
to see what are the conformational
changes which are occurring in the
protein
means i was talking about the structure
of lock so you can see like what are the
conformational changes which are
occurring in the lock
but here the lock is moving and you need
to know
like how it is moving so how
conformational changes are happening
how it affects the ligand binding and
not only that
you have a very another unique tool
which is called for covalent type of
docking so covalent talking is nowadays
very much
in the talk and very much popular
because in case of kubit
research there is a protein called m pro
and it has it is reported with the
covalent binder so that is why it is in
very well
known field now so for to study this
covalent binding and the phenomena you
can also study it using the schrodinger
so if we have module to do that
and of course if you go for higher level
of studies like you can of course refine
the
x-ray structure based on the electron
densities and based on the
energetics of all those residues so for
that also we have a module you
really don't need to rely everything on
the experience like we can
also do these things using you know
software and shooting assumed
so if you go for a higher level of
molecular modeling studies the quantum
mechanics is the often hard term
so we can also do the quantum mechanical
calculations ensuring the soup to
understand the structure and chemistry
of
molecule in between then comes to the
really really advanced modules
and i must say this is a very popular
module in
industry because it is giving
revolutionary result
and the module name is water map maybe
even if you can see
here so this is basically a tool which
uh helps you to understand the
thermodynamics of water
so thermodynamics of water it is very uh
the term which we heard in plus two
our plus two is a simple thermodynamic
like enthalpy entropy
changes and we can of course study those
enthalpic changes
whichever are happening in water and
when those are present inside the
binding pocket
and based on that you will come to know
about the very particular thing in
biology
and that particular thing is whether
your molecule
water is happy or unhappy when it is
present inside the bonding pocket so
simplest thing is you can see
here there are there is a protein
surface it's all
many water molecules which are
highlighted in sphere and those are
present inside the binding pocket
of the protein and you can see there are
a few
spheres which are water molecule are in
red color and are in green color so
green color is like a
happy water molecule and red color is
water molecule so once you identify
which one
which candidate is happy which one is
unhappy so
the simple logic it is always easy to
dis
replace unhappy one and it is difficult
to replace happy one so
overall idea is to replace the unhappy
one to design drug in better way
so this is what which helps us to
understand the water thermodynamics and
drug designing in better way
then here it comes the another module
called free energy perturbation fep plus
through which basically one can predict
the binding energy
of ligand molecule inside the protein
structure with the accuracy of
0.6 uh kilocalorie per mole and it's
very very rare
and i must say it is very much
revolutionary module which was by
schrodinger and you can see here in this
particular example like
with the help of software they could
replace basically
during the go like they could replace
the uh
they could adjust the another functional
group inside the ligand and because of
that functional group you can see it has
changed to
the halogen flow right because of that
chloride how much the binding energy
could change and we are going to see all
those things in more detail in coming uh
presentation so don't worry about it at
this point
just remember there are various things
which you can do it
with the schrodinger suit this is what
is the another example in lyo molecular
dynamic simulations like it
tries to modify the molecule inside the
binding okay and try to compute
its binding energy so this is what it
comes with the small molecule discovery
so it was all about
uh studying or small molecules or doing
the small molecule discovery
but uh i another module which i was
talking about is the biologic suit means
when
whenever you are working on proteins
antibodies
dna rna antigens
so if you are studying those kind of
things we
often call it as a biologics modeling so
we can do it with
schrodinger suit for example you can
design
antibodies you can humanize antibodies
can study
antigen antibody interaction you can
develop a model of protein using
homology modeling
you can study various phenomena like
protein aggregations and what are the
properties of
it not only that you can also study how
protein protein binds together how
protein dna interacts how protein rna
interacts
those kind of things you can study with
the biologic suit
and not only that even in case of if you
want to modify the protein it comes
under the protein engineering
for example residue scanning like
alanine scanning cysteine scanning
by sulphide prediction identification of
reactive residues
to engineer your protein in better way
to improve its activity
so you can just basically make a
thermostable protein for your
protein engineering stuff or to increase
its catalysis or to increase
stability so we can have those
applications also present in the
biologic suit and
when i said like discovery informatics
so informatics
whenever you work on various projects in
the field of computer educator designing
in chemo informatics you come up with
the huge amount of data
and it is not only about generating data
but
it is the discovery is all about
analyzing that data and get the
information out of it
so this is what the discovery
informative tools which help you to
analyze the data in real time
and not only analyzing the data but
consider
working live project which is going on
and 10 people are working on
single project at same time and
everybody is sitting across the globe
and still they can work it in a real
time all together they can do
all type of modifications at given point
and everybody
else will come to know about it so this
is what the type of
collaborations which we could make we
all we
call it as a basically project
management thing or
this enterprise discovery enterprise so
means everybody else come together and
they
start working on the same project and
this is not very much common in the
pharma industries and not only
industries
but even in academics you can have live
collaborations
where all scientists come together and
they work on the same
project at same time and they can get
more information out of it so this is
the way how discovery informatics helps
and not only that in disclosure
informatics is all about analyzing data
as i said so you can do various type of
clustering
to analyze the things you will have like
huge amount of data
when i say huge amount of data for the
hemo informatics
way means you will have huge discrete
powers uh huge amount of descriptors for
many billions of molecules
it finally interferes with the gigabytes
of data and you need a very powerful
tool
to analyze that data in various ways so
you can search it based on clustering
based on its fingerprint matching based
on its descriptors you can build various
type of models
we call it as qsr models and all those
things comes
under this discovery informatics to help
you to better understand the things
then uh things comes to the finally
visualization so visualization means
nothing but the representation of data
so at the end
you do your research project you come up
with a good results and everything but
it is always necessary
and very important thing is to present
that data in the nice way
so to to other to do that thing to
present the data in very nice way we
have a very powerful visualization tool
called imol
and with the help of that primal tool
like you can animate the thing you can
present it in the best way
so that it is understandable to uh the
researchers and this is also one of the
key point to get your data published in
good journals
or to get the recognition by getting on
the cover page of the journal so
this is what the live example we have
for the visualization or the data
representation
and then in brief about material science
so what
you can do with the materials and
material science so
you know like whatever is existing in
the world whatever you can see
is all materials it's all considering
the material
and of course we can consider we can
study all those materials like carbon
nanotubes or
nanoparticles or any type of material
even batteries you can study it with the
schrodinger suit
so what things you can study it with the
schrodinger suit is you can study its
energetic you can build various type of
complexes like metal complexes
which has very weird kind of geometries
and you can screen basically various
type of structures which helps you to
understand it in better way for example
here is a virtual screening of battery
additives
means with the help of this software you
can find out which
additive works better in your battery
and not only battery like
we can apply these things also in case
of designing the better material for
rocket
which sustain in the space at particular
temperature
particular pressure and all those things
so you can look for various type of
unexplored type of molecules
as your material for your particularly
for your particular study so for example
here is an example of
a film deposit deposition on the top of
some layer so you can also study that
so this is what it comes under
all molecular modeling so there is a
often
question people do ask like if i can do
the things with molecular docking itself
then why do i need that many rules so
so far if you remember like i have
presented like more than
uh 30 42 we so there are many such tools
which are necessary and why do we need
those tools and basically who are using
those tools is it really worth
to look for that many tools so my simple
answer will be yes
you need that many tools because the
thing is very much complicated
so if you see in the field of drug
discovery
the overall process itself is very much
complicated
and lengthy so if you have heard of the
process of drug discovery
from target identification up to the
drug in market it takes around like
13 to 15 years of time and that's really
huge time
yeah in that like 13 to 15 years like
generation get changed
and you really don't want to wait for
that many long that much long time
but we need to wait that's the critical
thing
we need to spend that much time on drug
discovery phases
and it's not only about time but it is
also about the money and
so in our world like time is always
money so
as you spend more time it comes with the
amount of salary for researchers many
researchers are involved in it their
time
their money so everything comes into
picture and it all end up with around
two billion u.s dollar
industry for each drug molecule and if
you calculate
it in a indian rupees it is almost 18
000 crore of rupees it's a huge amount
of money
so but if you see it critically there
are various phases of drug discovery if
you think smartly like where you can
work
on so you can see there are blue color
regions and orange color regions so
here is the orange color region which is
a more time consuming step for each step
we call it as a clinical phase most
preclinical
phase one phase two phase three and
basically as a researcher you can't
really
do anything much in this clinical phase
because whenever a
molecule gets put into clinical phase
it's a single
drug molecule which we administer in the
patients and study its properties
but we can't really modify that molecule
we can't play with that molecule because
what
we can do as a researcher is what
clinical scientists do they can they
observe the properties they observe what
effect
that particular molecule is uh giving us
in the body
that's it means they can only observe
the thing but they can't play with the
molecule
but if you see smartly there is an
initial phase of drug discovery which
spans for around six to seven years of
time
out of 13 to 15 years so you can see
like it all comes up with the initial
phases where you
perform high throughput virtual
screening you identify the target you
identify the molecule you optimize that
molecule
one
in short like you can play with the
particular molecule you can optimize it
you can perform various substitution
check its properties
and once it is all done you end up with
the one molecule
you put it into clinical trial and
that's it afterwards like human can only
analyze all uh
only look for the things which a
molecule does with our body
but the researchers can play initial
its role in initial phase of drug
discovery so with the help of computers
like we can work on that initial
phase at various steps and we try to
reduce the number of
animal studies we try to maybe as many
as possible number of molecules to
identify the best molecule out of it
and to work on this particular initial
phase of drug discovery
here the software comes into picture and
here that many tools comes into picture
like with the help of that many tools
you can study all type of millions of
compounds
thoroughly to get the best result so
this is what the necessary thing which
we need to do
to reduce the time scale of drug
discovery to give the better drug as an
output and why it is like
as such it is very much complicated as i
said and why do you need that many tools
because it's very much complicated and
to understand its complexity you need to
understand the thing
it is really really complicated so here
is the example
where you can have various drug
molecules and there are various number
of properties which you need to
uh consider whenever you design a drug
molecule like
it should have good binding it should
have good potency not only that you
should have good form of kind of
properties
it should have good metabolic profile it
should have good solubility and many
other thing it should not have any
toxicity
so there are many aspects and i would
say there are hundreds of such aspects
which you need to consider while
designing a molecule
and the overall drug discovery is
identifying about the star molecule
which
comes under all aspects and it should
satisfy all those criteria
so finding this star molecule is really
really really difficult and even i would
say it is harder than the rocket science
because rocket science also follows the
laws of physics and if you project the
rocket
we go in the right direction but if you
consider the same thing in
case of biological system when you put
drug molecule inside the body
you never know how it is going to be
affected so
we can't have any control on it just
like once you take the tablet you don't
have any control on it like
where it goes where it binds what effect
it is it can show any type of
effect and with the help of computers
the drug discovery scientist basically
our duty
is to manage all those properties in
this particular star
that is the reason i hope you got the
complexity of it
so the thing is one can get through all
those
things with the simple logic that if you
test
more number of components the chances is
better to get the
good molecule as the output and this
good number thing
like 10 20 years before that people used
to synthesize like 2 000 molecules
because that was the capacity of any
synthetic chemist
and out of which like they could end up
with the one molecule in clinical trials
and eventually if that get fails the
whole project get done
but now with the help of advanced
computational modeling we have softwares
we can basically screen
not only thousands but billions of such
compounds i would say hundred billions
of
compounds you can screen it with compute
with the help of computers rapidly fast
and with
accurate predictions and when we apply
this all computational filter you need
the chances of getting
a good molecule out of it is huge
and again like once you get that
molecule as an output with
with that huge chances the chances of
failure becomes less
but still but the still like you
whenever you put molecules in clinical
trial you never know like whether it
will pass or fail but
we can predict all those properties in
an early stage of drug discovery
to reduce that loss so this is what the
important thing which we need to always
consider as a discovery scientist
and here i would just like to give you a
brief introduction on uh
so i was talking about all those things
how how this software helps and one
should go
what are the things one should go with
and what are the ideal thing we should
consider
but this is what what actually happened
so in schrodinger we work on a project
called acetyl coenzyme a carboxylase
inhibitor design
along with the nimbus therapeutics which
is again
contract research and organization so
schrodinger and nimbus get collaborated
and they
they started working on the project
called acc and this is what the project
was mentioned by mr dragon initial
presentation
so they got the success by using all
type of computational methods and they
got
the molecule with ind approval within a
span of 16 month if you see this
line on bottom so it's the time scale
like they i didn't
they generated various type of molecules
initially they used computational
screening not only computational but
experimental screening on selected
compound they optimized the heat
molecule and finally they got the
lead molecule and they filed for india
and whole process took only 16 months of
time and this is not even 1.5
years of time you can see and initially
we were talking about
that initial phase of drug discovery was
for six to seven years
and now we have reduced with the help of
computational tools
with just 16 months and that is called
as acceleration of drug discovery
that is called as saving of money not
only money saving of time
so in this way we can accelerate the
process and the best example
is in front of you like kobe drugs we
have so this is what is the example of
accelerated drug discovery they could
screen the various molecules using drug
repurposing
and you got rendezvous as output against
the program and this is what people are
using
so if what happens because of
computational power and not only
computational power
but the scientists from various
disciplines when they all come together
and work rationally
the important word here if they work
rationally with the help of all tools
they could get successful
and this was the breakthrough like when
schrodinger got the
success with this particular molecule
within the span of 16 months
they sold this complete project to
gilead pharma and
it was for 1.2 billion they made huge
money out of
it so they showed to the drug discovery
industry like this is how
one could efficiently use the software
to develop a drug
against the target so this was the
successful example and
this successful example will be again
explained in detail in upcoming
presentations so don't worry about it
just keep in mind that we have success
story
and right now this particular molecule
is in phase two clinical trial and
it is along with the numbers uh
therapeutics
so in this way like with schrodinger
there were
there are many such projects which are
going on and many such projects are in
advanced stage and
not only with that even with indian
pharma industry this is the spark spark
is the subsidiary of sun pharma which is
the indian foreign industry like
even we collaborated with that